so we are back to the maybe the most
common target topic of this pi data
which is machine learning more less or
less no less and we will have manual
garrido that will talk about
recommendation systems so an applause
for all right well thanks for coming i'm
manuel and i'm going to talk about
recommendation systems first of all a
little bit about myself i work as a data
scientist at ascribing hub we are one of
the sponsors i was born in port well
I've lived in Spain most of my life and
I've spent the last four years in New
York in terms of my career path I start
as a consultant here in Madrid then I
move to an analyst position and then I
move to a data scientist position that
means that I followed in terms of tool
sets are very useful a very normal path
right let's start with Excel then
writing some vba macros fighting with it
d that is powered are and i was
mind-blown then are dealing a scale for
some reasons so i switch to python and i
loved it and not only i'm working with
very big data sets so i'm using spark a
lot lately that's my contact information
that's my personal website and do not go
there for two reasons first if you go
you will see a picture of my dog and
second you give up to that set to that
website and you do its last I data you
get the slides for top so in case you
want to take them out and that's my
Twitter handle and those are my
professional and personal emails oh the
a little bit of my company we are the
company was founded by the creators of a
scrappy which is probably the most
famous tool for were described as
premium python and we are specialized in
extracting data from online sources and
we don't help you or your company in
many different ways we have a super cool
team of engineers that basically can
extract data from any online source
literally any online source we have a
very big set of cool data sets that we
sell and that I get to play with and we
also have interview like to do things
around with a platform where you can
deploy your code and then you can just
run it by you
most important of all we are hiring so
if like me you like to play with massive
datasets just talk to me after the talk
we are fully remote company so you
shouldn't have issues with that I'll
give the talk its entry level that means
that you have some experience with
recommendation systems there is a slight
chance that you learn nothing it's going
to be focused on examples that means if
you want to follow along I don't see how
many people with laptops but if you want
and you have pandas above pointing 17
you come numpy or optionally side by you
can clone the repository and then you're
going to start at you bitter notebook
and you have all the code there and so
you can run it along could you guys
raise your hand if someone is going to
follow because I will go slower 02 all
right cool so tell you guys start
calling that so it's also on the PI data
repository cool so what our
recommendation systems that's the basic
Wikipedia definition as per video
recommendation systems a subclass of
information filtering system that's it
to predict the rating or the preference
that that user will give to an item I
don't like the definition for me very
simply recommendation system is
basically as it's in the provide
recommendations and that's all you need
right how do those systems provide
recommendations for that unit
information and that information can
come from a wide variety of sources most
common ones would be information about
the items themselves for example if the
industry blue or is it a sneaker is it a
high culture then you have also
information about the users right you
can tell oh who they are how do they
interact with my items have they
explicitly told me their preferences who
do they know and then and this is also
very important you have the plat for
information things like stop what's this
w have a certain item item are some
items do they have expiration dates are
there some business goals that you need
to implement all of these are sources of
information that you can use and you
should use to plug it into your
recommendation system this is a certain
similarity because nobody explains what
similarities and any job and it's very
important is basically like the core
concept of any recommendation system and
you might think oh I know what went to
start to see are similar but in terms of
data science similarity matrix there are
wild variety of similarity matrix and
some are used better to define
similarity between certain entities for
example if you are measuring similarity
among strings one common metric would be
the Livingston the edit distance which
is very simple it basically measures the
changes you need to do to a string a so
it becomes a stream b example to turn
rig into herb you need to do three
changes you to change the letters a
direct combat use magic would be the
jacquard index which is very useful when
you're measuring said similarity for
example if you want to measure the
similarity of two groups of friends one
way you can do it it you can measure the
number of friends that are in both
groups and divided by the number of
friends that are in either one of the
groups that will occur index then you
have another set of common similarity
matrix which are basically distances you
have the Manhattan distance which
basically measure the distance between
two points in right angles then you have
the clear one which is basically the
geometrical one that we have we have to
point we just measure the straight
distance and then we have the cosine
similarity which measures the cosine of
the angle between two vectors there are
many more bio in terms of my
recommendation systems approaches there
are many approaches most common ones
will be content filtering collaboration
field train then you have hybrid systems
and then you have the other because you
always need to have another analysis
basically and I'm going to talk mostly
about the first two but now in a totally
without the other other there are many
other ways they will trade around if you
want to but for example demography
recommendations let's say you have a
website and you are lucky enough that
you have demographic information about
your users then you can just classify
that users into those strata and then
you can use that to recommend based on
which is strata user belongs to you can
gather information yourself or you can
use research for that and then you have
social recommendations which is
something that everyone does nowadays
any time you click the share button on
our website and you are sharing it with
someone you are basically doing an
explicit recommendation to someone you
know let's tell a little bit of content
filtering content filtering is approach
or
mendation systems where all the features
are derived from the items themselves
that means that all the all the
information comes from the items it
doesn't come from the users that doesn't
mean that you don't need user input to
recommend things you need to know who
they are but that info is only used a
recommendation time not the moment you
are building the features themselves one
very clear example made for those in the
US I know here it's Pandora in case you
don't know bandura which I wouldn't be
surprised it's basically the most
popular radio online radio in the US and
first time you join since Pandora
doesn't know anything about you you see
that right you see hey tell me which
sounds genres or artists July and then
Pandora uses that information to
magically build an online radio for you
and that online radio the cool thing is
you can continue adding songs or artists
and it will get to know you more the
more you add the more you get to know
you the more personalized
recommendations are pandora is based of
the Music Genome Project which is afraid
that claims to be the most in-depth
taxonomic music basically bandera has a
team of musical analyst that every month
they review 10,000 songs 10,000 new
songs and then they map them into a set
of 450 features and then Pandora uses
those features to provide
recommendations these are just some
examples here on the level of
recommendation of features that the hood
and as you can see they are like super
specific right you have things like
subtle use of their harmonica right and
those things make sense for us so they
are you money you mail interpretable but
they make way more sense for an expert
in terms of pros and cons of content
filtering be pros is that when you get
the new user you can recommend that you
say right away because the information
you need is coming from the items
themselves so i can do you hate with
some do you like oh I like this sure I
can recommend you right away another
very good print is that you can apply
domain no that's right pandora has these
experts that know more than anyone our
music so they can recommend better than
us big con is that you need to map every
item into the whole feature space so for
example let's imagine that Pandora gets
a new song and it's a son that doesn't
fit into those 450
features but that it requires a brand
new feature because it's a very new
style abusing then the analyst will need
to a at the feature and then then it
would need to map all the songs in
Pandora to that feature an electron is
that recommendations are limited in
scope because you are pretty finding
them and their base of the items for
example who can assume that 450 are all
the features that you need to recommend
music maybe it's a thousand maybe it's a
million we don't know now over the first
example a practical example for the two
guys right here so basically we're going
to build a very simple content filtering
recommendation system and it's going to
recommend movies and we're going to use
the movie lens data set which is I think
it's released by the University of
Michigan it basically had like a massive
amount of more information on one table
and ratings information about the movies
and an arctic sea in this case is
content filtering where are we going to
use the movie table first we import
pants and numpy and we load the movies
table which is very simple it basically
has the movie ID the title and the
genres that that movie belongs to the
darkness are defined as a string with
the generous separated by a pipe so you
have to a story is animation by
children's pipe comedy so first thing we
do is we turn into a set of dummy
variables splitting on the pipe and then
for each movie we get a vector of cereal
and once with one's been those
categories or genres that movie belongs
to and that's how it looks then let us
remove a reducer and we know that the
user has watched those movies that you
should love action movies and sci-fi and
some children movies that's all we know
how would we recommend new movies to
this guy first of all we get that users
preferences and we do this very simply
in this example we basically get from
all that movie stable we just get the
slice of the movies that user has
watched and then which was posted that
means that for that user we get a set of
pros the categories of the movies and
then CEO someone's depending on which
movie then we calculate the average by
the category and then we just get those
numbers
we get that feature which would be like
0.6 66.com a 30 point 33 etc and that's
the feature of that user's preferences
in this case we see because of the
movies he watch that he likes action and
adventure and some children if you have
to only hate western movies example so
now what we can do is for that user we
can get the predicted score that that
user will get which is super simple we
basically that movies features which is
just basically a slicing on that movie
and we get that feature of series of
ones and then we do the dot product with
that user preferences and then we'll get
the number and the lemare by itself
doesn't make much sense but we got
comparing between movies it gives us a
very good idea of which movies you like
for example for this guy that liked
terminate the like action movies and
sci-fi terminator gets a higher score
than scream because this guy didn't like
horror movies that much so how do we
build our final recommendation system in
this case we basically just put all the
things we learned before the get movie
score function and we basically for a
set of user preferences which is that
vector that we got from the user because
of the movies he watched we yes either a
throughout the movies and then we
compute the score the predator score for
that movie that would be there when you
assign the score comp and then basically
you just need to sort by the score
descending and then you get on the top
the ones that will get a higher score
and then you just return that they
different so in this case because this
guy like action movies and sci-fi and so
children what do you get the
Transformers because it's like action
animation children sci-fi it gets
everything he wants right and you had
star wars because he liked some of the
Star Wars things like that the cool
thing out of this case is we started
with movies that this guy had watched
but what if he was a user and we need
you know information about him well one
easy thing we can say is hey tell us
which category do you like so you get
the right number 25 for its category and
then the user goes in the first time
similar to pandora and he says oh I like
action a lot and I hate animation so in
this case these guys giving us the
initial feature list for this guy for
this user giving us
preferences and then we would do the
same I will be a similar similar
recommendations and many questions are
we good there good good cool now we're
going to talk about collaborative
filtering and collaborative filtering
it's a more modern approach I mean some
companies still use content filtering
and basically in collaborative filtering
the features are not coming from the
items but they are coming from
individual user information so it like
their behaviors or their attitudes
basically you are used in how the users
interact with your platform to create
features to recommend the cool figure
this is suddenly now you have like a
very big massive data set of information
to play with because you have all the
use of information there are two basic
approaches one would be I tend to item
collaborative filtering in which you
measure similarity between items and
then you recommend those items and then
you have user item color are the
children in which you get similar users
and then you recommend the items from
those users that would be the thing to
normal and see like users like you about
these or red did that would be identical
over the filter one example of ident
wide and collaborative filtering would
be amazon of i think three years ago i
think now i have changed completely but
so basically when you go to amazon to an
item page you see at the bottom users
about these also bought eggs how I'm not
gonna start doing these is they
basically calculate similarity between
items purely based on which items were
frequently bought together so this is
how Amazon set up their sugar to the
code for the algorithm so basically for
its item then you go to each user who
bought that item and then you go to
every other product that that user
bought and then you just record the
intersection between the two as a pair
approaches and you have that for all the
items so then to get the similarities
with one item yes computer similarity
with the other items and I think they
use cosine similarity at first for this
sample somehow example of user item
collaborative filtering it would be
Facebook
though they use a complete different
approach the graph based approach
basically when you go to people you may
know on Facebook what does it do it goes
to your friends and then it goes your
friends friends who aren't your friends
I recommend them as friends and that
makes sense I've I've really make little
sense right just other friends so I
would be aye sir user ID amigos versus
go into the users the pros and cons of
collaborative filtering the press would
be that it can recommend new items
without you having to map them manually
right because you are not carrying about
the items themselves it's one very good
pro is it doesn't is the main hangar
state you can just plug it to our
website that sells potatoes or to our
website that sells movies as you just
care about interaction between your
users should work and that an a good
price that he can recommend based on
here features for example if you're
recommending movies and you use
collaborative filtering it won't
recommend based on categories which are
humanely huemul interpretable they will
be they will recommend probably based on
combination of actors on combination of
certain scenes that certain see the
movies have and that's very hard to hard
code by a human for example a very big
[ __ ] is what is called the called start
problem which is since do you need
information about the users to recommend
until you don't have information about
the user you can recommend basically and
another issue is that since every
interaction effect the features you need
to recompute dissimilarities much more
often that with content filtering for
example and now we're going to go to
another example in this case we're going
to build a very simple recommendation
and infrared it you can actually
dissipate friend of mine if you go to
that site to find this out you can go
there will at you authentication you
will get your super edits and they will
recommend some so in this case is item
to item because we are going to use
information about the users to a
similarities of the items and then we'll
recommend those items basically we'll
get the set of subreddits that our user
will give us and they will recommend
similar credit to him or her in this
case in terms of similarity metric will
will use the jacquard index data is
plenty for so the union /
intersection of a set and on that data
said on the repository there was a
compressed database that you should
consume to decompress it it has of the
data about the spray basically that it's
a very simple civilized database the has
two tables it has the raiders table and
the similarity table and the rate of
table is the most important one it
basically has 1.8 million comments we
users so it basically has two columns
the Raider column and the subreddit
which is basically a registry of use of
writing a message on a spread very
simple how we would compute similarity
based on this table since we said we're
gonna use the jacquard index it's breezy
with two queries per a combination of
subreddits and then we get on the first
one we get the union that means those
users that wrote the message on both sub
1 and sub 2 then we get the intersection
which is those users that road in either
sub-1 sub-2 if they have none in common
the return 0 but they have just do the
division and that's all so with this we
can just apply that to any survey that
we have information about so for example
aviation and flying they have idea card
index between zero it has 0.1 the
cardenas goes between surround one by
the way so this is now how I calculated
the whole simulated devil but this is
how you could do it basically do a lot
of the subs and then and then for every
combination then you just completed a
spot that function before and then you
started on the database this approach
would take like days probably to run I
didn't do it that way so what is
populated the table for you so you have
the similarity table with all the
similarity between the top adding ten
thousand subs so basically we sort them
by similarity we get the most similar
subreddits and that's set and we see
that they are basically clones of each
other where you have like imaginary
characters and millinery monsters it
makes sense that they are occur among
the most similar one you're alive Cairo
which i think is a kind of diet and
kettle recipes so there are very similar
to grab it so how do we build the
recommendations
stem with these similarities it's very
easy basically for well we will that
utility function that gives us the
subreddits producer and then given are
ready their name and the number of
recommendations do you want to provide
it's very easy we just go and here I'm
doing two queries because of how the
similarity it's not sorted always by the
first one being the the first one in
terms of ideal order but basically you
guys get those two credits that the user
has written two and then you stand a
similarity of the rest so whether you
are getting a sum of similarity of the
other subreddits based on those that
that user brought to and what you have
all the sum then you just same thing as
before you have short by the sending and
then you had returned the data frame
with the number of recommendations that
you want so it with an example I don't
know that guy just I like the name so
this do sir it has first we're printing
this relative road to and we see that
this guy has a very I would say like the
diapers an idea he's a liberal he's very
interested in politics because he has
written to political discussion as
social science madhuri politics as
polities the history somehow in religion
because he has written to islam and
other ISM change my view also so when we
recommend for him what do we get first
one we had a very liberal subreddit
which would be environment but then we
get a lot of politic related to brain
and those are so realize that that user
would probably like based on the
subreddit stuff you wrote oh yeah so
basically all that that would be one
example and then i think i might have
time to do all the examples maybe i'm
going too fast no am I going too fast no
oh cool then let you in our example
we're gonna do on our collaborative
filtering but we're going to talk we're
going to use the same movie lens data
set that we use before we loaded the
movies table that had basically
information about the movies but now
we're going to use the ratings that
users give to movies to get the features
that they will use to recommend move it
so basically first we load the ratings
table
which is a very simple table it has the
user ID the movie ID the rating and the
taste timestamp that user assigned
outraging we don't carry out the rate
the timestamp so we delete that column
and then we basically are merging with
the movies tables so we get like the
title insert the movie ID it's easier to
show you here with the title you
wouldn't need to do that in production
so basically this is how the table looks
so you have the user ID then the movie
title and the rating that the juicer
gave so first thing we do is we
transpose it we do a pivot table so we
get the user IDs as rose and then the
movie titles has columns and then on
each intersection we get the radio so
move user ID 1 movie title Star Wars
whatever this guy gave a file the
problem with this is since there are
three seven hundred movies this matrix
is super spars that means if a user has
given as a sign a hundred ratings that
means you have a hundred values and 3600
knows one way to reduce this is by doing
some simple data and petition and what
we do is for every movie we remove the
nose with the average rating for them
moving very simple and to reduce the
user bias we just for every row for
every user we did that the mean of that
user I will do this for one simple
reason some users love to be fives they
give five to everything they love moving
some other usually eat once because they
are like dirt you know what I mean so do
detect the mean and then you are
reducing the bias or there are critics
that's other content yeah so that's how
it looks how the table looks after after
normalizing this way and the metric the
similarity metric work when I use in
this case is the priests or moment
product-moment correlation coefficient
p.m. CC and this is a very simple metric
that given two vectors or points it
measures the similarity between them
with a value of minus one if they are
completely inversely correlated that
would be w0 if they are not correlated
at all and then won there completely
correlated to do so we're going to use
numpy super cool coracoid function which
does this for you it requires a matrix
so we just get the what is it works with
a different now okay watch with a dozen
that's good basically we just posted
because remember they died elsewhere as
columns since we went to get similarity
between movies then we need to turn them
as rose so I think we just transpose and
then we calculate the similarities
between movies this gives us a matrix
that has basically pairs on movies so
now we get movies as columns movies as
feel as rose and on each intersection
the p.m. CC for those to move it for the
same movies always one because they
always correlated but that's what you
get from these metrics so now that we
have the correlation matrix shall we
recommend it's very easy first you get
that utility function that get the
correlation for one movie that given one
movie Idol a title just get that Row the
row of a PMC sees for them for that
movie and then to get similar movies
then you just set up a threshold so you
say ok I will consider similar movies
only those with a PM CC of 0.2 or above
so then you are you're filtering you're
getting the most similar one for example
you when I get the similar movie star
wars a bit of 5 first of all I'm not
removing the same movie I should have
but what is the most similar movie to be
so far episode 4 of course and but then
you have also be so 5 episode 6 and
Indiana Jones because they are very
similar moving if you decide with die
hard what you get the same die hard they
hurt you that had three little weapon
and terminator so we can see that this
approach is giving us super similar
movies yes with one moving how do we
recommend items to a user Halloween
Roman movies it's very simple basically
we set up first an empty array of zeros
based on the length of the movies so
3706 I think and then for each movie on
that users movies we just get that row
of PMC's for that movie and then we have
some we continue serving at the end we
got like a some of those correlations we
assign that on a dataframe column and
once again we start by ascending and
will return the top when this case I
return the whole day after but
return the set up so for example we had
sampled user 21 which is a very clear
example of someone who has loves
children movies and animation think I as
I guess is for someone someone like a
parent a father or something that's just
writing kids movies I know so this guy
really likes animation and children's
movie so what I think I'm going very
fast no so if we apply this function to
this user what happens we apply the
function and then since he lied
animation and children movies what do we
we are basically all the Disney catalog
here so with all the children and movies
and they are most of their accommodated
so musical's so we get very good results
for that guy and now I'm going to talk a
little bit of hybrid models with hybrid
models well hybrid systems are basically
a way in which you can lead the cons of
content filtering and collaborative
filtering because remember with canto
filtering you get limited features but
you can't recommend right away with
collaborative filtering you have the
cold start problem so need some
information to recommend so what you do
is you can do basically first when you
know nothing about the user use content
filtering we just recommend and the
moment you get information about the
user then you start using collaborative
filtering or at the end you can just use
a weighted model hybrid model that
combines both to recommend one clear
example of this would be netflix netflix
when you go to the side you see fur you
see the top the top recommendations for
me for example that we base of
collaborative filtering but then when
you select one item you get similar
items so it has a combination of
information about the content itself but
also information about which users watch
what basically a little bit about some
libraries in Python all right I start
away with earlier a little bit our
libraries in Python the one I like the
most is Python Rex's then you have crab
which I think it's called cycle
recommender I don't know if that's
official but they follow the cycle learn
API then you have I checked lite FM with
which was announced like three months
ago
I think up by data Amsterdam that looks
pretty good adding that use some kind of
is the singular value decomposition but
the use also the item me da da da not
only the user rating for that and I are
a lot of time so I was supposed to
finish here but I'm gonna finish here I
don't know a bonus exercise and we're
gonna do pull our the filtering by
singular value decomposition which it's
simpler that in looks like so what is
singular value decomposition or sbd well
SVD is a matrix factorization method
basically what it does is it turns 1
matrix into a product of matrices so
given a matrix a which is n rows by the
columns the singular value decomposition
origin three columns with you being the
left singular vectors of the matrix V
given the right singular vectors of the
matrix and Sigma being a diagonal matrix
that means everything is serious except
the diagonal and the diagonal will have
the eigenvalues of the matrix run from
higher to smaller uvr or tonal and what
yeah and Sigma is Diana what are your
values basically it's hard to explain
but you will say when i get ballot would
be if the matrix multiplied by a nonzero
vector you get the same value of data
value which is color what did x value
matrix so the fullest BD is quite
positional intensive but what you can do
is you can say okay I don't care about
the whole again values of that matrix so
just give me the top cake since we know
they are ranked then we gotta okay so
give me like a smaller smaller matrix
that has has similar information but
it's quite a smaller so this is a way to
perform dimensionality reduction so you
are getting a similar not the same
matrix but that is much easier to deal
with one very good thing about this is
like we said with the matrix with the
matrix of users and ratings the initial
one is super spars you have multi null
values by doing this you just complete
videos that's parsley so what we are the
same thing well I'm loading the movies
again just so we have it fresh
supposed to be a complete independent I
don't pin independent problem we load
the red team's once again wears the same
as before we are getting now I user
index since we're gonna do one matrix
and all the user IDs are not one to n
there are some that are missing that we
just get the mapping so then we don't
get the user the user index and a matrix
based on the user ID so then we get the
would do the same thing with people same
as before now we're not using the titles
while using the ids and basically we
turn we get that data frame which look
like that which is super spars why we
have everything know I've said you say I
get ready 1 radio to verdi one with a 5
for example so here we're going to do a
different way of data predation and this
comes from a paper that is very cool it
I think it's called filling the empty
gaps on a user movie on a user item
matrix at the paper so one approach they
do to do the repetition and this kind of
do sir movie ratings is they use that
formula basically they use a mixture
mean where they get sign an alpha to the
users average rating and beta to another
alpha to the movie average rating and
then for each missing value they use
0.45 to buy the users average and they
some see your point 5 4 h by the movies
average so that way we this takes quite
some time for the guys trying to run
basically I didn't do it very well just
iterating through all the movie so it's
doing quite a bit so basically you just
get the ones that are no do you just
remove them that gives out the matrix
that is normalized but at least it has
no missing values then we normalize it
because for any matrix factorization any
dimensionality reduction you should like
pca you should do some normalization so
we just turn into a matrix and then we'd
reduce that we subtract the mean of the
matrix and then what we get is now we're
going to use SVD s which is the sparse
method from Sify for calculating
singular values of a musician
this way this doesn't give us the
fullest VD it just give us like I said
the top tech maloof so basically as VBS
returns the same three values that I
explained on their matrix before the
problem is that i have null matrix oh
[ __ ] here i have 15 minutes oh that's
why okay okay so not gonna go super fast
so the avenel matrix is written as a
vector so we need to turn it back into a
diagonal matrix that's why we iterate
and we assign zeros we're just basically
converting into ordinary on our matrix
and then we do the dot product and then
we get there SVD the composure the
truncated SVD as it's called of matrix a
let's call xeler right this is that's
how it looks and it has the same shape
as the original one so I had the 6,000
user under 3,700 movies and now the cool
thing is now if we wanna get the
predictor ratings for one users since
that that matrix holding similar
information theory on one then we just
need to totally just get that vector of
that user and those would be the scores
that the user could give you so if this
user well one click no one genome i use
k 100 which is the number of eigen
values that we wanna select I mean idea
you would test it's a lot to get the
optimal one that provides the best
accuracy score I just 104 anyway so we
get the same users before who if you
remember if you like like a lot of
animation and children some comedies and
adventures but mostly animation children
stuff so basically we do the same thing
but here we don't have to do anything
for that you say we just get that user
ID using the index that we used before
and then we just recommend right away
because we had the whole table with all
the information for you guys that have
heard about the netflix challenge the
freak chance was a contest and every day
2007 that gave money to whoever beat
their algorithm and it was one of the
main approaches that they did to to
recommend magnetic and thanks again
that's my dog so we have some time like
seven minutes for questions yeah thanks
a very basic question and how to handle
very tricky and manual data entry and I
mean if there is some spelling can the
levenshtein or Jack card index handle
this or you need the wild cards so
you're assuming you are getting the
extra for the user and you're putting it
into the into your data set itself well
you shoulda never do that right you
should first normalize and then what you
have the normalized data and you know
that it looks right then you put it into
your system so that could be done
through other methods that you know like
you said it's free similarity would be a
very similar one facet much in you know
that if you want we can talk after the
top more questions okay thanks again